- I want to know what you
guys want to hear a rap about.
So every person here think of
a word or a topic or a phrase
you'd like a rap about.
- (female audience member) Sea sponges.
- Sea sponges? Okay.
I guess that counts as coral, not animals.
So I will accept it. Yeah.
(audience laugher)
And wait, what did you say?
- (male audience member)
I did say the Fifth Ocean,
the Southern one.
- The Fifth Ocean, we
did we did just add that.
Didn't we? Cool. And
that feels pretty nice.
Cool. So sea sponges in,
we've got a new ocean guys.
Was it the sec someone over there? Yeah.
It's getting, getting confused.
Everyone is like, "Wait,
there's more than two oceans?
What the fucks going on?
There's the Atlantic. There's
the Pacific and, okay, cool."
So let's come to this over here.
We've got sea sponges in
the new Southern ocean.
What do you guys want to rap about?
- (audience shouting suggestions)
- One second, you're not
in that... Wait, sorry.
Someone is saying sponge
Sponge Bob and anal,
which is worrying me.
(audience laughing)
What is it from down here?
Is it Sponge Bob and
anal? Is that what it was?
Okay, cool.
- (audience member) Sponge Bob!
- Sponge Bob? Is that
literally a child over there?
That was Sponge Bob, yes.
In my country, called
Sponge Bob Square Trousers.
Um... Okay. So front segment
of the room on this level,
what would you like a rap about?
- (audience member) Tony Soprano.
- Just Tony Soprano? Okay, cool.
(audience cheering)
- (audience member) Gabagool!
- Imagine if he said a character
of any other nationality?
and you then shout it out.
Something that sounded like
that. That's, okay, cool.
So Tony Soprano and a guy going gabagool.
I know he says that.
I've seen the show. Okay.
Middle, middle segment of the room.
What do you want to rap about?
- (audience member) Taco bell?
- Taco Bell? Okay.
That's pretty popular with
a large amount of the room.
I imagine there'll be quite
a long queue at the bathrooms
after this show.
(audience laughter)
Back of the room, what
would you like to rap about?
- (audience shouting suggestions)
- There were so many of you, but,
what was the one that ended
with the factory career?
- (audience member)
Charlie, his factory career.
- Oh, Charlie's factory
career? Oh, wait, you?
Oh, shit, yeah.
(audience cheering and laughing)
- Cool. Okay. So just to recap guys,
we have sea sponges in the
Southern Ocean, Sponge Bob, anal,
Tony Soprano, Charlie's factory career.
And what was our other one
that we had over there?
- (audience members) Taco Bell!
- Taco bell. of course, Rhett and Jeremy?
Just, are we able to like mix it up
and do it kind of differently?
I know that you,
that we did a beat in the earlier show,
but I kind of wanted to keep
it a bit more like chill.
And can you like, is that doable?
Like, is I don't have
the energy to keep it
like a hundred all the time.
So let's uh, yeah this feels good.
I feel like I should be wearing a tuxedo.
(audience cheering)
Nice. Okay.
So freestyle for those of you
that don't know. It's made up.
It's not ran. It's not prepared.
It's not rehearsed, and it
will not be as bad as your
expecting a privately,
educated, middle-class white,
British boy to be. Let's do this. Nice.
- Jeremy raps: I'm in the ocean.
The water. I'm taking the plunge or
a report about the shorts
and I'm checking out the
sponge. When I'm down there.
I got the tank upon my
back. I love the sponge.
I can see it in the volcanic crack.
Cause they kind of cluster
around the little geothermal vents.
I was in the Southern Ocean
and I'm making sense before it
didn't exist. But then
they add it on the globe.
The little ocean. All
of ya'll better know,
I be off the coast of India.
Maybe South Africa. Take
a sponge from there.
I'm going to have a bath with you.
Do it like a loofah.
Scraping off a starfish.
Picking up the sponge like
of updating the starfish.
I say, yeah, I've got them.
I'm going to take the cartoon,
one from bikini bottom.
He's living in a pineapple under the sea
and likes that intercourse, anally,
and is painful to him, yeah.
He gonna to catch this.
Take a fat rod in the ass from Patrick.
He's like, "yo, do me."
Let the octopus watch one cough. Yeah.
Masterbate with us and this
fine. This Sponge Bob orgy.
You see the meme on lines.
We your adore these,
and that's okay. It's going well.
After anal sex,
you need to clean it up,
like a meal after taco bell.
You feel that the chili going
through. So many enchiladas.
I should approve. I've
got a little crispy thing.
Get in that Chalupa. I take it right home.
And it just shoots through
you. It's difficult.
You've got to take a little
bit of water to rehydrate and
know what should order in advance online.
But I always forget, but
takes like 10 minutes.
What's with that shit?
How are they so quick there with my order?
Tony soprano. What's he want
when he orders?
At his little deli. At
his little sub place.
He just shouts, "dabagool"
from his dumb face.
And how did the end of the show ever end?
Yeah, it was just blackout, My Friend.
You didn't know whether
he got shot or survived?
Spoiler, if you didn't
make it past season five,
now the last coming year charming to me.
At the comedy show. Up
front, I'm seeing Charlie.
Looking at the guy while I rap.
Do you mind if I lean
forward, borrow your cap?
And rock it out like this? Yeah.
I don't mean to impinge there.
Hard to tell under the
lights, but Charlie's ginger.
Wearing a raglan shirt. It's two colors.
You're looking kind of similar.
Are these two brothers? I don't know.
But let me pop the cap right back.
I know you got an urge when
you worry, Young Lad, like
I'll tell you what.
Yo actually, I wanna go
work out in the factory.
No fear. Charlie getting that career.
Rise from the factory
floor. He's moving here.
Used to be a supervisor,
but he's rising up a ladder.
Nobody's like Charlie.
No one can do it better in the factory.
Let me get a lot of love and no hate.
What's the factory make Charlie?
Obviously, chocolate.
That's the pun on the Roald Dahl book."
That's a freestyle flow, and
this shit was off the hook.
(audience cheering)